with all the talk of the deficits that
we're entering in the stimulus bill and
all the money that's being spent on you
know though the bank bailouts and
potentially the auto bailouts the
question that everyone's asking is is
this going to lead to inflation and that
is what I hope to address in this video
and I guess a good starting point is
well what is inflation well it's it's
it's a general increase in the price of
goods and services so you know they
actually measure it by they take a
basket of goods and services and they
see how those prices compared to a
reference here and if those prices go up
by 3 percent you know they they might
use a Consumer Price Index they'll say
inflation increased by 3 percent so
that's what's inflation and the opposite
of inflation is if things actually get
cheaper is deflation if one year a 10
megabytes of RAM costs X dollars and
then the next year it costs a little bit
less it's actually a deflationary
process at least in that market so with
that with those definitions out of the
way let's talk about a little bit about
what causes it a couple of days ago I
made these videos on cupcake economics
where I talked about you know what
happens when the cupcake factories have
high utilization or your lower
utilization what that might happen with
prices and the reason why I did that is
because I really wanted to make it very
clear that it really is utilization of
factories or of people that drive prices
so if I have let's see if this is all
the capacity that I have when I talk
about capacity in this video I'm peaking
in very general terms it's all of the
goods and services that we could produce
we could just talk about labor capacity
and then unemployment rate is a is a is
a measure of what is essentially not
being utilized but let's just talk about
that this is just our capacity our
production productive capacity and that
those cupcake economics videos I show
that if if the demand is pushing up
against capacity let me do demand in a
different color if demand is really
close to capacity and I know everything
I draw kind of looks like balance sheets
but this isn't intended to be a balance
sheet this is intended just to show you
the demand is pushing up against
capacity so in this situation let's say
you know this is capacity if demand is
at 90 percent of capacity then the
people with the capacity
you might say gee instead of trying to
just try to sell that extra units this
is demand instead of just trying to sell
that extra unit and have to worry about
all the raw materials and have to work
for that extra unit why don't I just
raise prices right when when so the high
utilization let me write that down high
utilization of capacity it leads to
prices increasing and this isn't some
kind of fancy macroeconomic principle
it's true if you're running a lemonade
stand if all of a sudden you're starting
to sell 95 percent of your lemonade
you'll probably say hey maybe it's worth
it if I raise the price on the other
hand low utilization let me pick another
color low utilization oops
low utilization sation will lead to
prices dropping and you go back to your
lemonade stand and you say wow you know
with if if I'm only selling 20% of the
lemonade that I make maybe my problem is
that I'm not making I'm not I my
lemonade too expensive and frankly if
there was a bunch of lemonade stands
everyone is trying to sell their
capacity so just to compete with each
other there are all lower prices and
actually I'll throw another thing in
here that's a little unrelated to
inflation but high utilization it makes
prices go up and it also makes people
want to add more capacity right so it
also investment goes up both of those
things to add more capacity but we won't
worry about that right now
so if you accept that and I think it's a
reasonable argument because it's it's
really based on I think common sense
things then I think you'll buy the
argument that if you have very low
utilization it's difficult to have
inflation and likewise if you have very
high utilization it's hard to avoid
inflation and to kind of hit the point
home actually I took our company's
Bloomberg terminal and copied and pasted
these these charts here and the orange I
know you can't see it that well on
YouTube so I'll try to make it clear
with my drawing but this orange and I'll
do it the same color this orange shows
capacity utilization and the starting
date right here was I think it was 1967
1967 this is 1969 roughly nine
team actually December 31st 1969 so this
is 1970 beginning of 1970 this is
beginning of 1980 beginning of 1990 this
is 2000 this orange line represents
capacity utilization so up here this is
90 percent utilization and then down
here this is 70 percent utilization so
if we look here in the late what is this
this is the late 60s right here we had
very high utilization arguably because
of the Vietnam War we had factories
running at capacity to build bombs and
Agent Orange and God knows what else
and then utilization went down you know
we could talk a lot about the history
but in general the interesting thing
well actually before I go into kind of
what happened let's think about what
this white line is so the orange line is
utilization up here we had like 90%
utilization very recently this was like
2007 we had 80% utilization and then
very recently utilization has dropped
off which essentially means we're not
you know running our factories at full
tilt this white line is year over year
inflation groans let me do that in white
this is year over year inflation groans
I'm actually let me draw a zero line so
we can separate inflation from deflation
so let me see zero inflation is right
it's right over here that's zero
inflation and you see in this time
series that I've done it we've never had
zero inflation although we have had
periods a very high inflation but the
interesting thing in the just falling
into the cupcake economics and this
whole notion of capacity utilization is
that capacity inflation inflation era
periods are always preceded at least all
the data I have by increases in capacity
utilization right so this is kind of you
can view this let me see if I can mark
this up you could view this as the
beginning of a pretty significant
inflationary a pretty significant uptick
in prices right and notice it was
preceded by an uptick in capacity
utilization so if you saw right here
while capacity utilization is starting
to go up and actually an end of the
interesting thing is to see what
threshold of utilization starts to
trigger inflation
so over here you say okay when inflation
really started turning around we were at
a capacity utilization of roughly I
don't know 83 84 percent right there and
then if we look at the next period where
inflation really started to hit you can
either pick that point or that point
where was capacity utilization it was
around that same level it was right
there it was above 80 this is about 82
percent and we could pick every period
before that so like when did inflation
inflation well you know since that
inflation really hasn't been a major
problem you know these are our mate are
two major bouts of inflation in the
early 70s and in the early 80s and those
were when we had extremely high capacity
utilization right extremely so the point
I want to make here is capacity
utilization really is the driver
inflation and you actually could find it
the other way around so this white line
here you don't see it because the orange
line Oh actually I realize that I'm
showing you off of the screen but let me
actually let me actually reduce my
window so I can show you so this is more
recent where we see that capacity
utilization started falling off I think
this is in the summer of 2007 and you
don't see it there because it's
overwritten
but the inflation line has also dropped
considerably it comes down to here but
notice once again utilization dropped
off although here it's pretty close but
utilization dropped off a couple of
quarters before inflation dropped off
and that's why I always wonder why the
Federal Reserve Board of Governors they
always talk about different inflation
indicators and what to do about interest
rates when you do have a pretty good
indicator and that's capacity
utilization now the next question that
everyone has okay fine so you know
capacity utilization drives inflation we
can all buy that but clearly clearly
what's going right now is kind of just a
wholesale printing of money and won't
the wholesale printing of money drive
demand to go up and then you will have
very high capacity utilization and then
we'll have inflation or even
hyperinflation and my argument there is
that's normally the case normally when
if you increase the money supply
normally if the money supply goes up
that should
increased demand but there's a subtle
and it's almost a philosophical point
but it's an important one to realize
money just allows you to express demand
right let's say I really really want to
buy a Rolls Royce I just don't have the
money if someone gave me $200,000 into
my pocket then I could express that
demand to buy the Rolls Royce on the
other hand let's say I have everything I
need I'm happy with my Honda and you
know my two-bedroom apartment and
someone gave me a $200,000 so they've
increased at least my money supply will
that increase the demand for the Rolls
Royce no I have money to express demand
but I won't do it just because I don't
think it's necessary so you can make
that same analogy in the economy as a
whole where you can imagine an island
where let's say there's you know there's
five of us or let's say three of us
because I don't want to draw five people
and between us we use seashells as a
currency right and we're very confident
and you know maybe I'm the I'm the
Builder and this guy is the fisherman
and she's the I don't know she's the
farmer and then I use in let's say in
one year I use a seashell to get some
fish and then he uses that seashell to
buy some crops then she uses that
seashell to buy a house and I use it
seashell again to buy more fish so you
can see that that one seashell even
though my money supply on that island is
one seashell it can transact many times
on that in that year so the velocity in
this example is very high right so you
notice that my expression of demand
happens in these actual transactions and
not all go to kind of the classical
money supply equation soon but you could
imagine another reality where for some
reason I don't I you know I stopped
trusting this guy I've become very
cautious and I say well you know what I
don't want to give him my seashell
because I'm not sure if I'm going to get
that seashell back again to do something
else so you could imagine a reality
where you know the central bank of our
island all of a sudden they find
hundreds of seashells and they put
seashells in everyone's pockets you know
so we're all full of seashells but all
of us are have just lost so much
confidence in the economy or is so
unsure
or whether other people are going to use
my goods and services that I don't want
to use their goods and services so we
all just start hoarding seashells so
this is a situation where the money
supply could actually increase pretty
substantially but since no one wants to
express it through demand it's not going
to increase utilization and so in the
situation that we're in right now if
we're if you're wondering about whether
you're going to see inflation or
deflation my argument is look at cat
capacity utilization people can point to
the money supply they could say that yo
you know money supply and this is the
classic kind of money supply equation
that the money supply times the velocity
of money that's how often Villette the
actual dollar switch hands is equal to
the price of the average price of goods
times the total quantity of goods and
services we have so most people say wow
if if the money supply increases then
won't prices increase well that would be
true if you assume that velocity and
quantity are constant but we're saying
and whenever you have major shocks and
people lose confidence this velocity can
slow down considerably especially when
things like financial intermediary start
hoarding money and people start putting
money into their mattresses in fact
oftentimes people don't even consider
things that aren't being transacted
money for example those commemorative
coins that they sell on TV they are not
considered part of the money supply
because people don't use them as money
anyway I'm all out of time I'll continue
this discussion in the next video